beyond the massive health implications
the wuhan pandemic has upended our lives
it's run our economy into a complete
tailspin let's face it well it's worth
quickly reviewing what we know and what
we still don't know about the current
outbreak now for starters we know that
Koba 19 is only the latest coronavirus
to infect and kill people across the
globe we know what happened with other
coronavirus outbreaks in November 2002
SARS or severe acute respiratory
syndrome was discovered in southern
China it infected more than 8,000 people
worldwide and had a death rate of 10% no
one died in the US and it was largely
over by July of 2003 the first case of
MERS or Middle East respiratory syndrome
occurred in Jordan in April 2012 first
thought it was from Saudi Arabia that it
was linked back to Jordan it spread
believe it or not through contact with
camels and closed person-to-person
interactions such as caring for an
infected person now more than 2400 were
infected globally with over 850 deaths
only two cases were ever found here both
in health care providers who had
traveled to Saudi Arabia
the case fatality rate was approximately
35% and then of course there's the
newest viral beast kovat 19 so far these
are the stats the virus is in more than
150 countries and territories with
nearly 200,000 infected nearly 8,000
deaths in the u.s. were just now ramping
up testing thank goodness and so far we
have nearly 6300 infections and 105
deaths and we know that most of the
victims are elderly or otherwise infirm
individuals but there are many important
questions about this virus that remain
and the answers are going to tell us
whether the mediation actions we've
taken you know the sheltering in place
and what we're doing now we're right or
wrong too much or too little
number one the true mortality rate as
the Guardian reported today quote we
yet know how dangerous the new
coronavirus is and we won't know until
more data comes in estimates range from
below 1% in the young to over 14% among
seniors or the medically compromised now
here in the US it seems that the more we
test the lower the mortality rate that
makes everyone feel a little bit better
doesn't it
well that graph tells the story number 2
contagiousness people are terrified
they're going to get the disease by just
walking by someone on the street or in
the grocery store and gonna go out to
get milk or by sitting next to someone
in a doctor's office for just five
minutes but dr. Richard Martin ello an
infectious disease specialist at Yale
New Haven said there's still so much to
learn about how this pathogen is
transmitted between individuals data is
needed not only to better understand
when those who become ill shed the virus
but also which body fluids contain the
virus and how those may contaminate
surfaces and even the air surrounding
them there was also an important study
conducted by Stanford researcher on the
on the confirmed in the instance of the
virus spreading person-to-person in the
u.s. it was a woman in her 60s who
returned to the u.s. from China in
mid-january of her 372 traced contacts a
study published in The Lancet found that
she's only they've only detected
transmission of SARS of this the
specific name of the disease that's
that's the corona virus we're talking
about in a single household contact with
frequent prolonged interactions with the
index patient that's interesting out of
372 contacts only one person who
basically lived with her her husband got
it number three why some people get sick
and some don't we don't know why some of
those infected experience only mild cold
like symptoms that resolve on their own
while a significant minority of those
infected may have serious symptoms that
lead to pneumonia and even death now one
theory is that the severity of symptom
is linked to the strength of a person's
general immune system but that's just
one possible explanation number four
patient zero we still don't know who the
first patient was who contracted the
virus in China now that's a key fact
that a lot of researchers say is
essential to the analysis of this
disease now we first heard that it was
like late December then it was December
first and now reports take it all the
way back to November 17th now this means
that the corona virus started spreading
for weeks before the first cases were
officially reported by China and that
brings me to the question number five
trusting the Chinese as soon as word got
out about this new potentially deadly
virus the CCP began to crackdown on
journalists for doing their jobs for
example the New York Times reported in
January that when a group of Hong Kong
journalists went to the Wuhan hospital
that took in most coronavirus patients
the police detained them for a few hours
they were then asked to delete their TV
footage and hand in their phones and
cameras for inspection and today China
announced that it was expelling American
journalists from the New York Times The
Washington Post in the Wall Street
Journal they cited ideological bias
against China fake news made in the name
of press freedom and breaches of ethics
in journalism well China's motivation
here folks is obvious it further allows
them to deprive us and their own people
of real information accurate information
on what the heck is going on and what
happened originally with this
coronavirus I regret China's decision
today to further foreclose the world's
ability to conduct the free pass Free
Press operations that frankly would be
really good for the Chinese people in
these incredibly challenging global
times where more information more
transparency are what will save lives
and speaking of saving lives we still
don't know what the fate is of the two
citizen journalists who disappeared last
month after questioning the government
government's response to the virus
they're just gone question number six
China's relationship with the w-h-o
remember China is co-founder of the
World Health Organization and it
provides an enormous amount of funding
to it they're now the second largest
donor after the United States but
somehow they seem to be pulling all the
strings CNN's reporting that the WH
o--'s praised of China's response have
led critics to question the relationship
between the two entities perhaps one of
the most overt examples of China's sway
over the w-h-o is its success in
blocking taiwan's access to that body a
position that could have very real
consequences for the Taiwanese people if
the virus takes hold there so when you
hear of officials here or journalists
even commentators lauding the Chinese
containment of the virus take that all
with a very large grain of salt and
remember while we're wise to heed expert
advice from trusted US sources during
this time we should also remember that
there is a lot we do not know and a lot
of information coming from China that we
can't frankly cannot trust and that's
the angle